late here we go starting a little bit
late
uh welcome to dr sadler's philosophy
forum number three the second one
actually turned from a hangout on air
into a regular hangout so it wasn't
recorded
and i'm going to talk about some of the
things that i i mentioned
in in that one where we had a great
conversation about plato
this one what i want to actually focus
on are some paradoxical
aspects of plato's texts
and some of the things that he's saying
in them and how they would apply to him
i'm going to try to do that without
turning into darida who you know wrote a
whole book about
that sort of thing on on plato in part
because i want to get
at what what what's going on with
platonic texts and as we're reading them
and thinking about them as practice
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
talk
for a bit about um some of these ideas
mention a few passages that i think are
particularly key
i can already see some questions on the
the q a app so i'm going to be answering
some of those but i'm going to try to
put them
into the context of talking about plato
mimesis and poetry
and very often so here's here's where we
can start out very often plato is
interpreted
as somebody who's hostile to
representation to imitation to to the
body
to anything material uh and
in particular hostile to the poets
because after all he wants to kick the
poets out of the republic at a certain
point doesn't he i wrote in the mesis up
here on the board but it looks like uh
you know things are mirror image
switched so you can't
actually see that mimesis and imitation
um kind of funny thing to think about
right there there's already some
self-referentiality in
you know the mimesis that's taking place
through this
mimesis is the greek is it's this greek
word and it's kind of rich it can mean
copy it can mean imitation it can be
talking about the actual product it can
be talking about the process
and if you think about what we're doing
when we are acting when we are
thinking when we are speaking
or you know producing other
significative
things like making signs writing things
down
we're engaged to a large part in
imitation of something in
reproduction in in representation
so you know one one good place to start
is thinking about
words and what words actually do if i
write a word on
on a chalkboard the word somehow
represents signifies the
the thing the activity the whatever it
is that we're trying to
to get at with it and notice that there
can be a great dissimilarity
between what is being signified or what
is being pointed at
what is being gestured at and the
imitation of it you know sometimes
copies are
things like you know we could take two
two pens
and these are in a certain respect
imitations of each other
you know here we're talking about
function but we're also talking about
the fact that they're straight
but um they're different colors from
each other
uh the plastics are are different this
is a softer plastic this is a harder
plastic
this is hexagonal this is uh this is
round
uh the caps you know look quite
different from each other
and you could say that in a certain
respect they're imitating each other
they're imitating the notion of pen
or you know the function of penalty
you know coin phrases if you buy into
something like plato's conception of
forms
then you would say that there's there's
some sort of
form of pen out there and they are
imitations of that
and without necessarily tying ourselves
to any one
interpretation of exactly what can be a
form and what cannot be a form
because there's some some dispute about
that and i don't even have my mind fully
made up about that myself um
one of the things that we can say for
plato is
is it's very clear and i'll point to
some some important passages
with that that show this it's very clear
that he thinks that there are
some things out there and he calls those
the forms
and those are most real those are
the objects of of knowledge when we
really do have
knowledge and those are the things that
other things that we're used to looking
at thinking about
talking about using referring to they
actually participate in that that form
they have they have the what they are
the the essence of them by participating
in that form and they do so imperfectly
and they can do so more imperfectly or
less imperfectly
to use one great example that's not
something
quite so tangible as a pen uh plato will
talk about the form of justice
and we can you know we can figure out
some things what what justice looks like
i think probably many of you are are
used to the notion
of you know justice is this balance
within the soul
you know like like plato talks about in
in republic book four
and you know he's got some some
metaphors about the city
and the soul being like a city and
having these three parts
and notice already we're engaged in in
mimesis
when we're doing that we're engaging in
kind of copies and we're doing it in our
heads and we're doing it in discourse
and we're referring to outside things
we're not referring to that
form justice in whatever
it happens to be the world of the forms
you know this immaterial
existence and yet
at the same time here's what plato's
committed to
that justice that we're able to talk
about
and develop a better conception of than
just you know
those guys over there who think that
it's it's you know doing what's
what's expected from their society or
this guy over here let's call him
thrasymachus because you know we know
what he thinks justice is the
the advantage of the the stronger
we can have a better conception which is
more adequate
to the form and
we can participate in injustice
in several ways we can participate you
know with our concept
of it but we can also have justice
within ourselves
within not so much the body you know i
have to gesture
at a body because that's what i have but
within the soul
the person here's again very typically
platonic doctrine the person who
understands
justice is the person who actually
has justice and understanding
and having and having is also means
acting with
acting out of these are all interfused
with each other they're not
interdependent so you know for plato
from plato's perspective it wouldn't
really
be justice that somebody was able to
have
an account of without being themselves a
just person
and all of those participate in this
this form of justice which all of the
things that we call just are just
imperfect copies of
which means that the justices that we
see in ourselves
in actions in a society
even in our accounts of justice are not
entirely just
they're not entirely what they are the
way that the forms are
instead they are as as plato says both
true and false at
the same time and they're subject to
refutation so you can take
somebody a human being for example who
we would say is just and we can give an
account of
him being just and you know he does
participate in that that form of justice
but we can always find angles from which
to look at and say well he's not just in
this
respect he's actually unjust in this
respect
a lot of people interpret plato as if he
is
simply hostile to the world that is not
the the forms themselves the world of
material things that participate in the
forms
really what plato i would say is is uh
his attitude is more like these things
are just what they are they're they're
imperfect
copies and if you expect an imperfect
copy to be
the epitome here on earth you're going
to be sorely disappointed
and you're going to go round and round
in circles and you're liable to fall
into the mythology that he talks about
in in the fedo
and charts out where we place too much
reliance on the material things and even
on our conceptions of them
rather than on the the uh the realities
themselves
so you know we're now sort of knee-deep
in the the doctrine of
of the forms and i want to bring up a
passage and this is actually from
plato's
um seventh letter he says
um you know the context of this is he's
saying people have been you know
claiming that they're writing treatises
that that um
communicate my my doctrine and they
couldn't really do that if they really
knew what my doctrine is
here's why he says for everything that
exists there are three classes of
objects through which
knowledge about it must come the
knowledge itself is a fourth and we must
put as a fifth entity
the actual object of knowledge which is
the true reality
that's the form we have then first a
name
second a description or an account
third an image
fourth knowledge of the object
and he says you know if we if we think
about a circle for example
um you can have the the name circle
you can have the account of of circle
and there's lots of different accounts
that we could have
you can draw an image of a circle which
is by the way
never partic it's never completely
circular there's always some
straightness to it as he says
and then we can have our our knowledge
of it and even that knowledge
that we possess of it is not the
the thing itself circularity or circle
hood or
you know the form of the circle out
there
it merely participates in it and it does
so better than
you know just drawing the the circle on
the chalkboard or
or saying the word circle circle over
and over again
um or you know or does you could say it
in whatever languages you want you could
say
that it's you know it's going to be the
same sort of deal it doesn't unless you
actually know what the name
signifies or at least have some dim
presentment of it it's not going to help
you out very much
and plato goes on he says
um
when it comes down to these things
um they're they're unstable even our
knowledge is
not completely stable
compared to the thing itself and he says
um in those
cases where we demand answers and proofs
in regard to the fifth entity anybody
who pleases among those who have skill
and confusion gains a victory
and makes most of the audience think
that the man who was first a speaker
right
our answer has no acquaintance to the
matters of which he attempts to write or
speak
sometimes they're unaware that it is not
the mind of the writer or speaker that
fails in the test but rather the
character of the four
since that is naturally defective
even our knowledge but but especially in
material things by which we we sort of
you know
order things and and make sense out of
uh the realities that we're trying to
grasp
even those are to to some degree
imperfect they're they're not entirely
what what they ought to be
so this is all i think for for many
people
familiar ground it's it's you know the
platonic doctrine of forms
the difference between immateriality and
materiality
um plato kicks the poets out of the
republic this is a good you know
place to begin with his conception of
poetry in part because he says well
they're they're basically telling lies
about about the gods and
and quite a quite a few other things and
what you know what are some of his other
beefs with the poets well if you look at
the ion
and this is also reflected in in the the
phaedras
um the poets don't know what they're
talking about they they talk about great
things
but it's because they're they're
divinely inspired you know
the muses inspire them and then they
in turn can inspire the audience or
inspire rapsods who interpret them
and then they can inspire the audience
um and they can talk about things as if
they actually had
knowledge or wisdom about them
and you know take homer for example in
the ion
socrates ask this rapso this interpreter
of poetry who's very successful
what does your guy homer talk about and
he says well you know he talks about
uh human affairs you know how to how to
run the state
and and and uh how to get along with
people
and he talks about the relationships
between gods and human beings so he's
doing some theology
and you know as he probes further he
talks about chariot racing and he talks
about
war and he talks about this and he talks
about that
and the ancient greeks took um homer
as well as many of the other poets who
they thought were important poets
as communicating knowledge or wisdom
about about things so you know for
example in
in republic book one where do they begin
in their enquiries about justice with a
proverb by simonides
and why would they do that because they
think simonides is
actually on the ball he's got something
to contribute here he's got some insight
to
to give about that and plato
over and over again although he he will
have socrates sight passages from
from homer and from some of the other
poets his
attitude towards the poets seems to be
uh in many respects they don't actually
know what they're talking about
that's not always the case there's
there's passages in the symposium
where you know when you're thinking
about the nature of poetry it talks
about
um those who are are pregnant in in the
body
bringing forth progeny that are that are
you know just more human beings you make
a
imitation of yourself to to uh take over
after you after you've
shuffled off the scene or you've gotten
old and you're no longer yourself
but poets of two very important sorts
produce something that's more
lasting and there he talks about homer
and he says homer produced
poetry that's going to remain it's going
to last
over time and in um
well the other class would be
politicians and specifically legislators
who produce order
so he talks about solon who reformed
athens and it had a lot of respect to do
with you know
reconciling the the exploitative rich
with the exploited and very resentful
uh poor and changing the laws about debt
and slavery and taking nobody's side
actually taking everybody's side against
everybody else so as to to
bring about a harmonious conclusion or
like kyrgyz the
the spartan king who established their
their way of
life he he talks about
similar things in the phaedrus when he's
socrates is having this discussion with
phaedrus
and he talks less in terms of poetry
there and more in terms of
rhetoric another use of language another
use of mimesis
using words to get things done and he
talks about um
poets and politicians giving speeches
and some of these speeches
stand the test of time like a
constitution
that's a a use of of language
so plato's attitude towards the poets is
actually
complex it's not so simple as well kick
those bums out because they're telling
lies about the gods
you know and if they can't keep their
mouth shut about that sort of stuff then
they they can't be in our city
it's it's it's a lot more complex and
and nuanced
now here's where we get to what i really
want to talk about today so this has
been kind of a long wind up
plato is presenting himself
and his doctrine as being
relatively hostile to imitation to
mimesis
to to poetry but isn't he doing the same
thing
isn't he himself writing works
that are mimetic perhaps even to a
higher degree than that of the
the the poets the playwrights the
writers
of his own time we'll talk about that in
a moment
and isn't he in a certain way engaging
in his
own sort of poetry that is
production of meaningful
gripping discourse that
gestures at least towards higher things
and communicates knowledge to us
isn't he himself doing this and if so
what sort of attitude should we take
towards him should we say ah look at you
you dirty hypocrite we can dismiss you
entirely
i think that would be a deeply mistaken
point of view
um i even think that you know dario's
notion about indecidability and all the
sort of stuff that he he does and
playing around with
this especially playing around with the
difference between writing and speech
um coming out of the phaedrus that story
about thoth and
egypt and all that i think even that is
kind of
kind of off base i think part of what we
ought to realize
is that things are more complicated
for plato and for us if we want to take
his his dialogues and his doctrine
seriously
and something like what kierkegaard
called indirect communication
occurs on multiple levels
through his dialogues i think that's
probably the
take to to to move to and so before i
start answering some of these these
questions or addressing some of these
questions
let's think about how plato himself
is in some respects the foremost
imitator the foremost poet think about
the wide range of
characters in his dialogues one of the
things that
makes for a good poet a good epic poet
or even a lyric poet
or a good playwright and the playwrights
were poets too because they're writing
in
in poetic meter and that that's a form
of poetic production
is the ability to represent
to engage in imitation of character
and character doesn't just mean you know
moral character
it means the ways in which people think
about things
our character isn't just whether we're
nice people or mean people or good
people or bad people
it's about how we reason things out it's
about
what we place is central it's about how
we approach things
and i started writing down just a few of
the classes of people that that plato
is able to imitate in speech down to
how they would talk prime example in the
symposium
you have these speeches by seven people
eight if you count the otoma and
each one of them in each one of them
plato himself
is representing how this kind of person
would talk about this
so you've got the the young you know um
phaedris who's who's just you know
giving this this wonderful little
aperitif at the beginning you know with
some interesting images
and it's kind of you know in some
respects it's kind of a hackneyed
thing at the very beginning and then
you've got pausanias
another guy who's a bit more serious and
he's interested in the laws
and you know how things should be
structured and even engages in a little
bit of ethnology
you know we would call it comparing the
different greek city states against each
other
and their characters and why they they
see things and then we get eric simakis
and if you look at eric simakis's very
discourse um he uses this sort of like
subject verb object or actually not just
subdivide object
subject is predicate
over and over and over again the word
the greek word for for is
shows up in his discourse much
more prevalently than um in in the other
speeches so he he is this kind of guy
who's like yeah everything's elements
and we can break him down into this you
know he's sort of a proto-scientist
and his discourse is deliberately
boring as a result plato's able to do
this
then you get aristophanes and you get
like this complete contrast he's going
to tell this wild story
about how he used to you know be these
beings that rolled around and if we
don't watch it god's gonna cut us in
half again and
and um plato tells it
the way that aristophanes would tell a
story
then he's got agathon and agathon turns
on the floodgates of gorgian rhetoric
then we have socrates and socrates does
his typical you know shuffle around and
talk about things and ask questions then
you've got deodorant and then you have
alcibiades coming in
drunk and engaging in this you know the
way drunk people do
this let me tell you about this guy
socrates and why
he's so great you know and he goes on
and that's just one dialogue and plato
is able to to
present to us the reader
2300 years actually more after
um this this culture and this guy is
is long dust things that can
grip us even today and he does this in
dialogue after dialogue after dialogue
so plato had incredible artistic gifts
for presenting people and he doesn't
just
present us you know like the highest
versions of them he doesn't say
uh you know i'm only going to give you
the best examples and let's
let's let's keep all the other ones out
of the picture the way that you know he
says that the poets ought to do
right he allows us to to grapple with
them
to see them how they are thrasymachus
comes on like a lion and
actually as we know sticks around after
socrates bests him
uh and when we see him him humbled and
we see him becoming friends with
socrates
afterwards um
there's a lot of elements like this
where where
plato is able to imitate
military men religious figures epic
poets
redders the sophists he's even able to
make the different sophists
appear like different types of people
so in the protagoras for example
protagoras is
one guy who's there and i think it's
protocus and somebody else
they're all engaged in in these
discussions
young men sound like young men old men
sound like
old men in in plato's discussion so he
is engaged in poetic production
one of the things that i think is is
particularly interesting
with respect to this and now i'll just
say this and then i'll start answering
questions or addressing comments
plato has this discussion that i brought
up
last time and i i mentioned that in the
end of the symposium
socrates um agathon who's the tragic
playwright
and aristophanes who's the comic
playwright are the only people left
awake
and they're arguing about whether the
same person can be
a comic playwright and a tragic
playwright
or whether this is impossible whether
the genres
and and acquiring not necessarily
perfection but but
skill in the genres
precludes doing so in other genres
and it's left an open question there
in the republic this is discussed in
in book three and
socrates is leading his his young
interlocutors and
he says um the same men cannot practice
well at once even the two forms of
imitation that appear most
nearly akin writing of tragedy
writing of comedy so neither can the
same man be
actors for tragedies and comedies all of
these are imitations
and so what what plato says is look
these are really close together
and the same guy can't do both of these
equally well
now think about the whole range of
imitations of things
in in life um
so and he's talking about the guardians
here he's talking about the nature
of their craft and learning their their
their skill he says um
do we want our our guardians to be good
mimics or not
if if they are then they can't be
imitating all sorts of other things they
have to be imitating
this craft and
is it possible to bring these things
together
this is also by the way related to the
the platonic conception
of knowledge or discipline or or skill
you know
techne or or episteme
where plato almost always has his
characters sort of separating these
things
out you know this is is conservative
this subject this is concerned with this
subject
um once we move from one to the other
there's no connection between them
that can't possibly be the case why not
because
who who actually is able to bring all
these together in speech
plato plato
and apparently his teacher socrates
plato is creating a new genre
the platonic dialogue
and within that genre he is tying
together
all these motley forms of speech
and trying to essentially produce
something like a drama where we get to
see
which forms of speech can can do well
and which forms can't and what they lead
to
and if plato was right about this thing
that you know one person can't imitate a
lot of stuff plato himself couldn't be
doing his own work
so that's a paradox and that's one that
that's worth thinking a lot about let me
um now
actually since we've got the question
and answer app um
let me address these and i'll see if
there's others on the
site so one of the first questions by
christopher dunn
is what are your thoughts on the idea of
utopia in in the republic
so uh personally i i tend to think that
um what plato is
is sketching out for us there is
not what plato is completely committed
to
that um he's saying here's here's a
model
of what the really really good society
could look like but it's still
if we take seriously this stuff about
mimesis and about the forms and all that
it's still representation in speech
isn't it and
he's doing it through this this dramatic
dialogue
so we should be a little bit skeptical
of thinking that he's actually
laying out an action plan for how things
should go it provides us with some
guide posts you could say so
when he's um invited to syracuse and
he wants to actually give some advice
about how to make their society better
which doesn't work at all quite frankly
read the seventh letter and
you'll find out all about this um
he's now trying to generate the republic
he's trying to take
a a unruly um
city syracuse and make some of the
citizens in it better
bring them a little bit closer to things
and get them concerned with their souls
get them concerned with
with the forms get them concerned with
doing the kind of assist the kind of
choices and discipline required to
orient reorient yourself away from just
you know pleasures and
whatever you know the opinion of the day
happens to be towards towards things
that are eternal
and lasting and more valuable and more
important
um so i i don't think that plato is
actually
he he is giving us a utopia i would say
he's not giving us
his utopia as his final word on on
everything
i think there's other parts of the
republic that are um
more valuable i think that you know the
the allegory of the cave
the discussion of the education
that would be required for for
philosophers
is he probably does you know he is
showing us his hand there but
the the city the way that he constructs
it
there's problems with it you know and
people pointed out this is totalitarian
he tries to address some of these things
you know with
you're going to make the guardians
unhappy um
the city can only be of a certain size
so it can't be
universalized if there was any such
thing it would be kind of an oasis on
earth
um that's my thoughts on those are the
the things i would point out with utopia
in the republic
another question by uh christopher dunn
where does the idea of mathematical
platonism
originate from well plato appears to
have thought that numbers were
either forms or something like forms so
they're these eternal
realities i hesitate to even call them
objects because
objects are you know is a sort of
sense thing that we're used to thinking
of or or objects of thought
uh are concepts that we have you know
sort of control over
we don't control the forms the forms at
best
you know were able to participate in
them
numbers are kind of a different sort of
thing you know if you think about what
the
forms typically consist in like you know
there's the virtues
there's perhaps forms
of certain kinds of objects
it's a little hazy about that there's
forms
in the sense of like metaphysical
principles
and then you get numbers over here and
numbers do appear to be
um something eternal something
that you know each each two seems to
participate in in
doubleness or twoness in some some
strange way
that's the idea of mathematical
platonism that numbers
actually are something that really
exists
and that concrete particular
even material instantiations of them are
somehow
participating in them reflecting them
imitations of them
and this would be opposed to a few other
views of mathematics and what's going on
in mathematics
like formalism or uh
intuitionism um
i suppose mill would kind of mill's got
his own kind of weird
notion that mathematics is all actually
empirical
um and those people would reject that
notion they would say no numbers are
like symbols that we use to
to communicate with each other about
these these things
um or they reflect you know what we
actually
experience we build up with them
um let me move on to the next one this
is kevin
l why do you think that the myth of
atlantis has been popularized beyond its
discussion in timaeus
and crittius plato's discussion of this
myth is interesting
but is there any philosophical or
cultural significance of the
myth um i tend to ignore it i i'm not
i'm not very interested in it myself
and i don't really think that there's
a lot of um
philosophical significance you can say
there's cultural significance but i
don't think there's a lot of
philosophical significance to the myth
of atlantis you know this
island being out there and
there's you know it's one of these sort
of origin stories
and it's kind of fun to read as a story
but it doesn't seem to be very
very important it doesn't seem to be
doing an awful lot i i think of other
you know plato does have recourse to
myths this is probably another thing
worth
worth
mentioning too in this terms of mimesis
plato you know tells stories
and he has socrates do this like
whenever things get to a real crux
and they're like well i think it could
be something like this story that i
heard from this
this person who maybe heard it from a
priest over here that you know there's
there
when you die here's what happens and
you know there's a lot of these stories
in plato i think the ones about the
the afterlife are more interesting or
like the story about
thoth and the the egyptian god thoth and
writing and why
writing which seems to be a really
really good thing for us an aid to
memory
actually turns out to be something
that's going to make us less
able to to remember less able to focus
on on what's
you know essential to carry it around
with us so
i don't have an awful lot more to say
about about atlantis
um
let's see
here's another one by the fates of
warren plato's theory of the forum seems
to be almost the exact opposite of
aristotle's theory of universals
but there also seem to be many
similarities why do you think this is
the case outside of their differences in
epistemological
theories well i mean
the difference in epistemological
theories is in part this difference
between
the forms and and uh the aristotle's
understanding of universals in their
relation to particulars in both cases
we're talking about the relation of
universals too
to particulars and i wouldn't
say that aristotle's theory is the
opposite of plato i would say that
the nominalism of some
philosophers that you find is the
opposite
if there is an opposite of of plato's
view
um aristotle is actually kind of close
to plato
he he just doesn't think he thinks that
the forms
actually are in the material things or
not necessarily material things it could
be you know in
in a grouping of things
um the structure
is is the form the what you know what it
is
what makes it what it is at least in the
respective of its
you know look or structure or [ __ ] is
what aristotle thinks about it
and aristotle doesn't think for example
that there is a form of the good
out there independent of all the other
good things
in in which all goodnesses participate
uh in part because he thinks there's
there's some some
well he raises a whole bunch of
objections to this one is well where the
hell is it
but there's other things like this makes
some things unintelligible and he points
out good is a
is a word that is said in many senses so
there's a number of different types of
goodness
uh spread throughout the different
categories and the
good is is a term that cannot be
brought to one single universal concept
for
for aristotle um
it's what you know later on they're
going to call the the grants and
it's one of them like truth like like
being
like unity jacques martin actually
argues for
beauty being being a transcendental too
but now we're getting like further into
like thomas aquinas
um there are similarities between
aristotle's and plato's
views of things in part because you know
aristotle is
taking off from plato if you if you were
to look at
aristotelian and platonic uh
epistemologies and metaphysics they're
really
they're not really epistemologies
they're they're metaphysics of knowledge
i know this may be a distinction that
doesn't make make that much sense to a
lot of people but
uh in ancient philosophy epistemology
does not drive things it's metaphysics
that that drives things
and you can look at the difference
between you know plato and aristotle on
the one hand and then say like the
epicureans
on the other hand or or the stoics who
are thorough going materialists
there are more nominalists in a lot of
respects
so let me uh let me move on to
okay here we go another one by the fates
of warned
back on the subject with regards to
aristotle and plato
tech we'll see how the term is being
used
not only the fact that plato's writing
cell was very poetic despite his
opposition to poetry but aristotle loved
poetry despite his analytical style
why do you think this is the case um
well like i said
i think that plato is trying to
communicate
things to us on on multiple levels and i
think there's some things
that cannot be communicated directly
because simply putting them in words
if plato's right is
going to sort of leave them defeatable
you know because everything is is
is imperfect you're always going to find
exceptions and counter examples and
stuff like that
and this is this by the way is one
reason why i think that
it's very difficult for analytic
philosophers to make sense out of plato
in the full sense
um not because you know oftentimes we'll
oppose like analytics and straussians
who want to
you know stress the dramatic elements i
think that we really need to take
if we want to read plato in his own
right we have to take seriously his
thoughts
about the adequacy of the very
words the thinking that we do
to to represent realities he doesn't
think that they're adequate and you'll
always find
counter examples but those counter
examples don't actually tell against
against against that um
so why why is there why is plato very
poetic because poetry is is
in some respects how we have to
communicate
things that that really really matter
and what are those things
questions about what's true and what's
false um
what's good or what's bad for us
and even in a larger sense
how we should how we should run our
lives how we should comport ourselves
what we should pay attention to
these these really big things do we
actually know ourselves
these issues that are what aristotle
will call
uh and plato will use this term too uh
dialectical topics things that we
have as big questions in part because
although there's a lot of you know
range of views that can be taken on them
they can't be nailed down
to to one thing very easily that we
could then put into a textbook
in a certain respect you could say that
plato is impossible to write a textbook
on
because what is the idea of a textbook
you can digest everything into little
chunks and
and put it all together by the way you
can't do that even with aristotle you
might say that aristotle has an
analytic style but aristotle is actually
a dialectical philosopher he likes to
canvas everybody's everybody's views on
things
and then see well is this part right
over here and
can we bring that over here and this
part over here doesn't look like it's
right let's let's see what we can weld
together
and let's look at the topic from
multiple angles
and we will try to you know break things
down which is what analysis is
but we'll also try to put it back
together um
and we won't mistake you know the
elements of something
for being the actuality of something the
the intelligent of something he's an
aristotelian term
um why did aristotle love poetry
because he cites it a lot doesn't he in
his works
because poetry uh is not just you know
fluff that we
do because it's fun and it's not just
ways in which we
we you know get laid on valentine's day
or something like that
poetry communicates deep abiding
truths when it's done well and
it does so through beauty it does so
through
things that grip us that that very often
don't just make us feel but make us
think and make us
see things differently so that that's
that's my take on that but i could be
completely wrong
about that uh let me skip down
it's uh um
robert knightness well reading mount
block
a footnote in the reading made reference
to wordsworth in his philosophy of
platonic amnesia what is this exactly i
don't i don't know
um because i don't know my wordsworth um
which is uh you know something
unfortunate on my side but
uh amnesia is the lack
of remembrance of things and
plato talks about memory and remembrance
in two different ways
there's you know the doctrine of
recollection where
we in a previous incarnation
actually not incarnation it's not the
wrong word because it means to be in the
flesh
in an excarnation when we were just
souls
we actually saw the forms the realities
and they were beautiful and they
impressed themselves upon us and then
somehow getting in
getting back into bodies again we forgot
all that
and when things remind us of that we
have this this
feeling of of recognition i i've seen
that before and we can
by carrying out platonic philosophy
not just as a body of doctrines but as a
practice
this is something very important about
platonic philosophy
it has to be something that's that
actually lived out contemplation
is an important part of platonic
philosophy
as an approach to things plato doesn't
say that you know somebody makes an
argument and you're going to
see the forums just like that he says
you have to work you have to work your
way
towards them and that's
the overcoming of
amnesia of this forgetting of these
primal realities
there's also memory in the sense of like
you know remembering
to go to the store and buy milk
or you know learning
learning uh geography for example
geography would be
you know i almost thought about learning
your times table but your times tables
mathematics and really that's kind of
you know
learning the forms of numbers but think
about geography
what goes where and who lived where and
how how do you get from this city to
that city
and do they have snow there or or rain
there
um that's all just sort of like
memorizing things about the the world
and and you could have amnesia about
that i think that
so we've got a contrast here between
remembering
stuff that you need to know and i think
a lot of disciplinary knowledge would
fall under this and then there's like
remembering
this deeper sense of getting at the
primal realities
that we we need to have in sight if we
really want to have a true view on
things and i'm guessing that you know
wordsworth in talking about
amnesia is talking about that that
forgetting the opposite of that
remembering
but again i don't know because i don't
i've only read a little bit of
wordsworth i'm ashamed to say
and uh i didn't really make much sense
of what i
read um andy hurt
he asks in the republic plato emphasizes
training poets using diction and rhythm
models for the semblance of good
character
uh he mocks the poets in the ion and he
employs poetry as a structure for
socratic pose
in the symposium why is a good word
multi-polar on poetry as
a device um
i'm going to complicate it a little bit
more and say
for the same reason that plato is
multi-polar
on rhetoric as a way of using
language as well because it can be done
well and it can be done
in a degenerate sort of just let's
please
everybody we have no idea what the hell
we're doing
but it seems to sell and it's you know
and and uh
i'm using some television metaphors here
uh the ad revenues going through the
roof when we do this kind of play
that sort of thing it runs the gamut
um poetry can be used
to do the really heavy lifting
that philosophy sometimes
can't do by itself
um or even if you think about you know
if we expand this to to you know the
realm of theology
if we want to use a very different frame
of reference
why were the psalms important you know
why why did people
write these down because they were used
actually liturgically
and they were used as poetry that would
move people that would get people to
think
and if you read through the psalms
there's a lot of solid thinking going on
there a lot of deep thought you know
about
about pressing questions and yeah
it's not sort of pollyanna stuff um
so you know plato is recognizing
that poetry has not
yet attained what it what it could be
used for
and he thinks it's the same thing about
rhetoric too and the phaedrus he's
talking
about how rhetoric could be used
for the good but that would require a
poet
or a rhetorician who actually
is a philosopher also in a certain
respect and knows
the you know knows through the forms has
has genuine knowledge about things
not just has you know sort of a knack
for what people like to to hear about or
read about or or and
it's not just somebody who's like
inspired and you know
expressing their feelings or things like
that
it's somebody who who
can really exploit the potential of
poetic language for for what it can do
um that that's why i think he's
multi-polar
as you put it on poetry as a device
uh it's a good word multi-polar
um
kevin l asks do you think that the
project of getting out of the platonic
hold on philosophy is worth continuing
and do you think any philosophers have
been successful in getting out of plato
entirely
i have in mind here someone like
nietzsche or heidegger
uh it depends on what we mean by the
platonic hold on philosophy i think that
a lot of
philosophers um never really
were held by by plato i think there's
ways of
doing philosophy that are just
very you know very different than what
what plato or even aristotle
um are are thinking that philosophy's
about so
if what we mean by the platonic hold on
philosophy is something like you know
being oriented towards
seeking out through contemplative
activity
as well as dialectic as well as you know
scrutiny of one's own life
as well as like trying to practice you
know
ethical behavior to to make ourselves
into better people
trying to orient ourselves to the forms
i don't think too many people actually
need to get out of that because i don't
think too many people are actually
in that um i think you know sometimes
they
they they're they're taking on descartes
and they're talking about plato you know
this this
notion of the uh the landscape
as being sort of like this this realm of
of pure intelligibility
and it's all kind of formalizable that's
not real platonism
as far as i understand plato and what
he's saying it's awfully murky
our thoughts you know we're hardly ever
in touch with the forms and we have to
really work our our butts off to
get a glimpse of them that that's that's
enduring at all
um you know nietzsche talked about
uh uh christianity is platonism for the
masses so you know
you can tell by the fact that nature
doesn't like christianity platonism is
going to be a bad thing in that case
right
what did he do not like about platonism
it's socratism
and you know if you read the birth of
tragedy that's where you'll you'll see
this in the first place
socrates wanted to subject everything to
questioning
wanted to generate knowledge that could
actually like you know
take account of itself and and nietzsche
thought that was that was a bad idea
that was putting us on the wrong path he
thought from socrates
and euripides to the sort of alexandrian
classifying everything nothing really
has any full meaning anymore
the gods have been evacuated uh it's all
about you know human beings and trying
to make sense out of
very small projects
he thought there wasn't much of a a a
gap and he thought that plato was
was part of that um
you know heidegger i guess
you could say that heidegger is wanting
to reject
a certain kind of platonism but you know
heidegger has got this notion of
of at vocal metaphysics meaning it
corresponds to epochs
and what he what he means by that is
that we've got being with you know a
capital b
and then we always have like a range of
beings that we use to kind of
uh understand we we turn them into what
he calls the typical
kind of of being and
the ancient greeks did this plato did it
one way
aristotle did it another related way you
know like with form and matter
and the medievals ended up through
christianity bringing in the notion of
the the you know
radical contingency of being and the
creator
and that was another way of of sort of
narrowly restricting being with a
capital b
and not seeing the other sides of it and
then we get modernity and in modernity
it's it's um this is what the question
concerning technology is about
it's this um very different attitude
towards
things it's not really platonic or you
know
christian medieval it's coming out of it
in certain respects but it's also
leaving it behind
and that's more of a pressing danger for
heidegger then
you know and going back to plato would
be um
i mean heidegger talks about you know i
gotta get back to the pre-socratics and
and all that um
but i think that certainly the plato
that we're talking about here the kind
of
interpretation of plato it doesn't
really
he's not the kind of guy who you'd have
to to worry about
so much if you're nietzsche or heidegger
you might they might he might even be a
little bit more congenial
um to you uh
let's see what other the
in the the sidebar these these questions
are getting thrown in there kind of
willy-nilly
uh
oh okay here glenn roberts what are your
thoughts on the relationship of plato
and the early christian church
so it depends on what we mean by early
christian church if we mean like the
you know the uh apostles in in their
small circle and then afterwards you
know the ones who got converted in in
jerusalem
and judea and then samaria and then you
know over an antioch and then moving out
that way
um really not much connection to plato
at all
and later on as as christianity is
expanding through the the roman empire
starting in the eastern roman empire
which is
you know deeply informed by by
hellenistic culture
uh and as more educated people are
getting involved with the movement
um now there's you know there's concerns
about
how do these things fit in with each
other and a lot of the church fathers
many of whom were by the way
philosophically trained
saw platonism is
um the closest philosophy to
to what christianity was bringing about
um closer to to what they were thinking
about then say
the stoics let alone you know those
those dirty
epicureans you know or anybody like that
um
but they didn't wholesale accept it
uh they often incorporated it and
transformed it and you know
there there were there were other
elements too coming from aristotelianism
and stoicism
that were brought in as well you can see
them showing up
in in you know monastic disciplinary
practices and the thought about how to
scrutinize the self and how to analyze
it
i can say this the platonic tripartite
notion of the soul played a very
important role
in uh christian anthropology within the
for the you know the egyptian greek and
roman writers it played a great role
in that the syrian writers don't really
know that well
so i can't i can't say
the other things that i will say is
there is this tendency to want to
claim that um
copied stuff from moses you know and
that was kind of circulating around back
then there
you know whoever had the most ancient
doctrine
like won the the bragging rights
but um that wasn't really taken that
seriously by
by the really heavy hitter christian
thinkers
that tended to be the sort of thing
they'd be like well yeah and there's
also this this notion over here
somebody like clement of alexandria
thought that greek philosophy
was another old testament
you know um that it was it was a
preparation for the gospel the way that
the the the way that christian writers
understood the
the uh older uh scriptures
and in their canon of scripture too by
the way they included some things that
are
fairly neo you know platonic texts like
the book of wisdom
um anyway they included that sort of
thing many of them they saw
greek philosophy at least if you had the
right greek philosophy and generally
that meant platonism
as a preparation for the gospel so they
saw some compatibilities
there um it's a good question
uh what else do we get
um another one by glenn roberts
how had plato shaped your personal
thoughts on the soul
well that that's a good one um
i'm more more
willing to talk about um
personality rather than soul
because i tend to be a kind of uh
christian aristotelian with respect to
this body and soul you know the the soul
is the form of the body
and uh it's kind of hard to say exactly
what what what the soul is
and um
you know i don't worry so much about
that i don't think actually that much
about you know
what's going to happen after i die is my
soul going to like flit away or stuff
like that
i'm more i am very interested in the
structure
is you know psychology
that's the soul the the doctrine about
it or the inquiry into it
it's in plato it's it's it's not just
about you know does it like go off here
how do you purify it
it's about how is it structured
what are our basic drives
what are the basic functions how do they
interrelate with each other
and can we strengthen them or weaken
them
should we be ordering them in a certain
way
and i like plato's views on that you
know i think that
there is a difference between
the thumatic desires the thematic
functions of our soul that are concerned
with
how we view ourselves in relation to
others i think there's a difference
between that
and our our appetites you know
gearing us towards food towards
plot you know pleasure sleep towards
towards sex towards
things along those lines of course they
can become combined together
uh quite easily and i like the fact
that plato even in the the top part of
the soul
it has its pleasures and desires so he's
not like well rationality means is
totally you know being totally devoid of
pleasure desire anything like that
um i i i like his uh
his his views on it um
that's probably yeah i'm i'm
more i'm more uh
into plato's notion of the structure of
the soul or the personality or however
you want to think about it
and less worried about where it goes
or if it's going off to see the world of
the forms
in between lifetimes or any anything
like that
yeah and i would say that a lot of the
authors that
i'm i'm interested in are also very
interested
in the structure of the soul and many of
them use that platonic
tripartite notion the soul one one
example of a you know a good christian
author who is reflecting many other
christian thinkers would be john
cassian this monastic uh church father
who is recording these dialogues that
he's having with the egyptian
desert fathers and they are
for the most part you know platonus when
they're analyzing the eight capital
vices which later on become seven deadly
sins
um some of them actually belong to the
lowest part of the soul the appetite
some of them belong to the thematic part
of the soul interestingly
some of them belong to the rational part
of the soul
the you know the one that's that's
capable of like pride and vain glory
actually belong there so
it's not just um how plato's shaped what
what elements of plato's philosophy
shape my
personal thoughts on the soul it's also
that he
shaped other people who i'm interested
in
and taking seriously and thinking about
um
i think i've been i've i'm supposed to
have been clicking on these
uh select things this entire time
for uh the answering questions i'm going
to try to see what that does
uh oh here we go it puts it in highlight
here is from the fates of warned how do
you think a debate between plato's
socrates and ludwig wittgenstein would
go especially concerning wittgenstein's
theory of language games
i i really have no idea i've never
thought about that
at all um a debate
uh i don't know that they would actually
debate that much
wittgenstein was not a
super communicative guy
especially if he was like trying to
think about something then again you
know socrates could like go off into his
own
la la land thinking about something for
for hours at a time as well
i can tell you this i
studied my wittgenstein under
a philosophy professor when i was a grad
student
who had herself studied under people who
were students of wittgenstein's
and one of the things that she told us
about this was
many of them had sort of gotten the
wrong they've taken the wrong lesson
from from wittgenstein because vick and
shane do a lot of weird stuff in the
classroom
and they kind of thought that in order
to be a philosopher you had to
you know kind of act like a weirdo and
they'd developed kind of ticks
or like one guy would actually go and
like thump his head on the wall every
once in a while
you know just like show that he was
doing deep thought
um and i you know i don't know how much
wittgenstein himself
like gave rise to these things but he he
um
he might not have been the best
interlocutor um socrates might have
might have been
you know like i'm not sure what you're
doing friend
why don't you come back over here and
let's let's chat about this sort of
stuff
um wittkenshine's theory of language
games if they were going to debate that
wittgenstein never really
completely clarified what language games
are
and that's something that wittgenstein
scholars have gone back and forth about
you know what's the connection between
language game and formal life can this
be a language game can you have a
language game in which there's a
language game
so i i'm not sure what he would have i'm
not sure what socrates could have
latched on to to actually
talk about with uh with wittgenstein
um it's kind of a interesting thing to
think about
um i don't know i i think there's
probably a lot of other
people who would make better dialogue
partners or socrates
than than wittgenstein um wittgenstein
you know of course would would
not like socrates constant emphasis on
uh trying to you know get definitions
because that doesn't fit wittgenstein's
notion of definition
uh whether we can't have definitions
about things
and i suppose that wittgenstein probably
would have pointed out something that
that
you know plagues uh socratic
um philosophy in general
at least in the dialogues that we have
which is this notion that somehow
uh disciplines are they seem almost like
completely detached from each other and
yet some can be
you know uh super ordinance some can be
subordinate and there's never any really
good explanation for that
in in socrates um at orton plato
and there's a lot of cases where
you know the same subject matter should
be able to be considered
by different disciplines and and
oftentimes plato will rule that
possibility out
i don't think that he really ultimately
believes that i think he's putting out
that there for us to
to struggle with but you see that
assuming a very important role like in
the uh
in argument in the ion in the carmodies
in the protagoras you know
it plays it plays a a role
and wittgenstein would have criticized
that i'm pretty sure
but where it would go from that i don't
know no idea
seems like you know wittgenstein is a
pretty neurotic guy socrates
is a pretty non-neurotic guy so
they might have actually gotten along
pretty well because socrates would have
kind of like balanced him out
perhaps
let's see if we got any other ones that
i haven't gotten to
um
it looks like i've actually answered all
the questions
that were asked in the q a
i see if there's any other
no whoa there are yeah there aren't any
other
ones in here
so i'm actually unless people come up
with other
questions going to start bringing this
to
a close
and you know thinking about some of the
the key ideas that we've
we've talked about that are coming up in
these these platonic dialogues
there's there's a paradox and this is
part of i think what makes plato
so interesting and so much fun to read
that he's not easy to pin down on
the issues of poetry there's there's
always more going on
in plato once you scratch the
the surface
and you start thinking about it and i
think that's what the dialogues were in
part designed to do
um it's it's interesting to think about
this because plato didn't write all the
dialogues
at once you know sort of like a composer
coming up with one
gigantic master opus instead he wrote
this one and then wrote this one and
he may be reconsidering ideas from from
one dialogue to the next
and these dialogues are just part of
what he's actually
himself doing you know he's teaching
in his his academy he also goes off to
syracuse to try to
see if he can't straighten things out
with some of the people there
he's you know he's himself engaged
in following out this socratic uh
project of attention to the soul and
trying to think about one's own
uh life and what one truly is
and whether one has cultivated the
virtues whether one's participating in
them and what what the hell these things
actually are um i think there might be a
few other
questions that have popped up
glenn roberts asked what role did the
constellations of the stars influence
plato
that i i don't really know um i'm not
sure
what what that would mean
uh and plato thought that that
you know the material universe is some
sort of reflection of some
some cosmic order but um
the actual
stars themselves it's not like he was
into
astrology some some later neoplatonists
were
were quite into that um you know who
else was into that whether the stoics
they uh because they were interested in
divination
but plato himself does not appear to be
particularly
concerned about that or interested in
that
um any
others well it looks like i have uh
answered or at least made a stab at
answering and addressing all the
questions comments that have given that
have been given to me
and uh talked about a lot of different
things oh somebody wrote a new one a lot
of different things all
all connected to each other uh well this
is a good one to end on
so uh daniel's uh
is it slotness yes this is great i just
stumbled upon this podcast
when is the next session i'm going to be
doing these uh these monthly
some of them i will be doing just by
myself
and i'm hoping to talk some of my
friends and colleagues
into doing some where it's it's uh both
of us on there you know
chatting back and forth and taking
questions and answers like
like we're doing with this so i'll be
you can find out about these is actually
a good question to
ask you find out about these by
watching my google plus uh profile or my
i also
put these on my facebook uh author page
i should probably publicize them in
other ways but that's that's the main
ways that i've been doing it i usually
put a little reminder on on
my youtube channel um and i'll be doing
these
hopefully every month one a month uh
i may be talking about plato the next
one i haven't actually decided on
the topic but i think i'll be going
fairly
sequentially so it's going to be mostly
thing
must be for for the time being and
they'll usually have this sort of format
i'll talk for a bit and then start
fielding comments and questions
and unless i have a guest on and and
that's what we'll do
so um i am going to call this one
to a close i thank all of you for for
watching and for your questions and
your time and attention i hope it's been
useful for you or at least
thought provoking and i'll see all of
you next time